le petit pontini une bâtisse de près de
600 mètres carrés situé en plein coeur
de chablis c'est dans cet espace chargé
d'histoire que s'installera la future
cité des vins nous avons la chance
d'avoir ce bâtiment et qui sont les
cellier des moines cisterciens de
contini qui au 12e siècle on construit
on peut dire c'est ici d'ailleurs que
les premières gouttes du chablis ont
coulé la notoriété des vins de chablis
n'est plus à démontrer
pourtant à travers ce vecteur de
promotion qu'il souhaite pédagogique et
ludique
le bureau interprofessionnel des vins de
bourgogne espère fournir aux touristes
les clés de compréhension d'un vignoble
réputé
ici c'est un parcours d'expérience qu'on
met en place on veut que les gens qui
viennent ici puissent expérimenter les
vins de l'yonne à la fois les vins de
chablis et les vins du compte c'est oit
pour montrer la diversité qu'on a dans
notre département
on aura bien sûr des rappels avec le
reste de la bourgogne mais on veut
vraiment qu'ils goûtent qu'il teste
qu'ils sentent la particularité des vins
de john cette cité des vins n'a pas
vocation à faire concurrence aux
commerçants de chablis des commerçants
qu'ils l'ont bien compris et qui voit
d'un bon oeil l'émergence de ce projet
nouveau et ambitieux c'est vrai que je
sais les meilleures façons de d'aborder
les choses peut-être pas que pour les
enfants
tout ce qui permet aux gens de repartir
en ayant fait des découvertes dans un
endroit ça aide à garder une affection
ou de la deux
la du vent je pense qu'il ya plein de
choses attache anti ch à billets et
c'est peut être une chose supplémentaire
2 millions d'euros sont nécessaires à
chablis pour l'installation de cette
future cité des vins les premiers appels
d'offres notamment en matière
d'architecturé seront lancés dans
quelques mois pour une ouverture espérée
en 2019